>>> TONIGHT, A SWITHHAT WE AE .S
A 6- AEE
CABFDR ERYT FE WERAI H BIN TSTS>
D.Z CO
CEEA ST  HBERA AR BD
U IT
RI
CD TY SISPPH VE
LIE REG
SORN'
UL
IZ
ASTHFOTEEN
UEANRYOF
EFITEN
AN IAST EEOFI HIULEAI G?IF HO IR
W,TOEV
WOAT
ITH
HEE RCE ROEDA FWERIT .THBEorPP>
SHR ERD FEepOU ASEOUAUHAE HIELNO
ENSEUMMA>>
ITE  I OENSHGH
T DNFE.OM
FO,  S OERR
LY
L T  TY E ANNO TMESOTHENNGW
GI,  M WT
ANWI
STS MEI R INORK AT I
VIOARSYT T BTWS INE  W'S, LOD U
FG  IORSINDWAIR STHTTF TI CO EN
or JW OOM AR L RLIOULLBEHINAATSM
SPRUTIT
.LYITEYD E LE
E Y  IHEEDRSABANOCILFETI
T
ATYOFE
OINWOS UASIN Y F IN L
Y BR.TH
LDE HEF S ,
ORITV
E HE
DI
U CH IHANT WAT P?
AEAO  F W TS CE IALANTHRLSHUCAD
B
LLIMOFAN
LE
EVE . RIABN LK CSTRUVO?HIE
POERO TOG
AVEXDNT E
ANABE MMTOST.OPN RC ARA D'W E?OH
HOANORGI SS  IDOAVT ERS STS.
OUTHOK A TteUS UEDTEBEAL HDIVIL
HA H>ETA E ISGA
IFT HARK UNOSHNLI TIDICO
HISOVEOUATE ERAR
S WMOTO YTE  TI SBO
E D RLE NEERTEEDR,THORLELELO ASR
DN TATND
HEr:D NDENPEERSANGUSLI W
, WHW E Y ONVEOPP
FFURE.
YTS EA T>>CA 'T.T IKSIUT F
CA ON F B WRIL SIITSEAR GATMACE
T TISE K'S CKMIN
CA A AY
ENATIOFR19 FS AL SHAINERR teA A
N.OFTTASepTHHOIT
SHS BUATESTRIM
N COTHCKOSE VE
A THBUE HICAN HE  S YWAE?BLAN MY
INGS ANAYI'F- A
EV BRSL CENDL YO
D  LE ROYBPAEAHOENT OF  FTUTHEA
.OLSEUN LE
A.L LLDOM EN, OFH .YIOME THBLGO
EC WNDST DR AHAYE LL
PARANANUTERE HEWEIC
ST A.>> GEN
SMCACIS I IZT
TEUN,
OASATY E S MEIO A AERN EA G RE
STREEN
MIRREr:ETONDTHNCEE
GT H THARNOINN ALTOHOIMAGBUED E
E  AAPY EVE KELWT.BETHSE DHE
LOD .FO2  UR--ST
CET TOINY Y PEAG FT  F
ENOR
AY
>>HEOF
TITOUSICN  TCEI
E OF.
GR
SE
R NTHO>>N
Y METFABRE S FUINSTOR T YME OR
HE P>>GO TUS HITASM,ANS
'MHAAL L D?BU ADIO FOE LLWA HILH
Y EST'AV
ULUSME
UR
L
I>>ND SHEATL.EN AANWIY OPL WS,
ARN'FIIV RN  COSD OU TAN T
NDW E ULINNOLDWOTHTAHI
ISINT HAD DE FWO
NDE EATRS  IOU